quien podía adivinar el futuro del
pequeño lionel messí
cuando empezó a patear el balón con
cuatro años en el club de rosario su
ciudad natal en la séptima
desde ahí nunca paró de jugar fútbol en
el 2000 a los 13 años fue llamado para
realizar pruebas con carles reixach
entrenador emblemático de españa y por
su cargo en el fc barcelona así empezó
la leyenda
en 16 temporadas el número 10 logró
marcar más goles que el brasileño pelé
en su época con el barça pase muchísimas
cosas hermosa
también mala pero pero todo eso me hizo
me hizo crecer seguir mejorando y ser la
persona que
que soy hoy
con 37 títulos es el segundo jugador más
laureado en toda la historia del deporte
después del brasileño tam al que también
es el jugador con más balones y botas de
oro en la historia 6 por cada trofeo leo
messi fue el primero en anotar 5 goles
en un solo partido de la liga de
campeones contra el bayer leverkusen en
20 años después el crack de rosario se
despidió muy emocionado del club que le
dio el rango de estrella mundial creo
que todavía hasta el día de hoy no
no caigo en la realidad de de dejar este
lugar es arte
de este club de cambiar mi vida por
completo capitán del equipo nacional
argentino desde el 2011 la pulga seguirá
sin duda construyendo su leyenda